i want to welcome everybody
my name is paul north i'm a professor in
the german department at yale
and this is the first in a series of
workshops
that carries the title the value of
marx's capital
obviously a little play on words there i
want to start each of these
episodes with a quote from the author
who
has been kind enough to come to our
screens
and this is a quote from terrell carver
who's with us today
it goes like this quote no one who wants
to read a work of history
even a history of capitalism will find
this book
easy to understand he's referring to
marx's capital
but then he adds capitalism is not an
easy phenomenon to grasp
or an easy one to live through
i want to recognize a whole bunch of
people
as we're starting first the director of
the whitney humanities center
alice kaplan for being kind enough to
let us try this experiment
in the middle of a pandemic i want to
thank
sandra malambols for her incredible
organizational skills and
lyanna hirschfeld crowen who is the
graduate student that has pulled this
all together
i want to thank also yes mean who is
going to handle the technical parts here
this is a set of workshops
that run in tandem with a seminar
in which there are about 25
undergraduates who are reading through
marx's capital
very carefully um
so i want to welcome the students in the
seminar
and then i'd like to thank the frankie
family
for making possible these lectures the
frankie lectures in the humanities
that is richard and barbara frankie who
gave this money to present important
topics in the humanities to a wide and
general
audience one of the reasons we're doing
this
is because i am involved in a project to
edit a new translation into english of
marxist capital volume one
and i have to thank my collaborator for
that paul writer of osu
whom i want to introduce to you now i'm
not sure you'll be able to see him but
he will come in later when
it's question time paul ryder is a
translator of some note
also a scholar of german studies and he
is rendering
capital volume 1 into an english that
you can
understand and that will also delight
you this volume should come out
with princeton university press
in 2022 we hope
now it's a great pleasure to introduce
terrell carver
who is a professor of political theory
in the school of sociology politics and
international studies
at the university of bristol in the uk
terrell carver has been a visiting
fellow at the research school of social
sciences of the australian national
university
at the center for asian and pacific
studies at ck university in tokyo
he has been visiting professor in the
states and
many other times in australia
in the far east most notable for our
interests is that he was a member of the
editorial commission on the german
marx engels edition the marx engels
gazumpt ausgaba
otherwise known as the mega which is the
most significant event
in the textual fund of
marxian writings ever
seems to me terrell carver specializes
in marx angles and marxism
and on the philosophy and methodology of
social science
he has written widely on political
theory but has a big bookshelf
on marx and engels specifically he wrote
the book on marx or
a book on marx that is marx in polity
press
from 2018 there are many
books on marks but there are very few
books on ingles
and terrell carver i think you would
have to admit is the world expert on
ingles
he wrote the book many years ago now but
it's still a very important book marx
and engels the intellectual relationship
there is no marx without engels as i'm
sure terrell would agree
this book is from 1984.
he wrote the life and thought of
friedrich engels which came out in 1990
and was reissued this year and
was a co-editor on engel's before marx
which is a very important book to
understand where engels came from
i'd like to give the microphone over
to professor carver but first i want to
thank him for a book that was important
for me
that's the postmodern marks which came
out in 1998 that's the first book that
made me think
i wanted to read marx so thank you and
welcome
uh well i'm delighted and honored to be
here
and so really pleased to hear that
comment about
uh that particular book uh i wish you'd
been a reviewer
but we'll get on with the plot
here this evening i'm also delighted to
hear that it's a workshop so
i expect to work out and i expect the
audience to work
too i think there are a lot of you uh
and i'm sorry i can't see everybody and
interact in
uh that way but we'll do what we can
with this medium uh thanks particularly
to
leanna and yasmin for uh helping me
along through
um some of this and i'm still tackling
the yale forms
uh as we speak uh but
everybody's very patient uh just a
little bit
of background i've been in the uk
for quite a long time but i am actually
originally american
so i'm just mentioning that so that we
don't
feel the need for a lot of intercultural
uh
translation exercises i actually
um graduated from colombia in 1968
i went to high school with a flag out
the front and took the sats
and did all of that so i'm not a visitor
who sort of
dropped in from mars although
paul north did say that with this on i
look like a helicopter pilot so
i thought we'd uh whoosh up and get
going uh with a few slides just as a
kind of warm-up so i'll see if i can
share the screen here
and set up
a powerpoint which just looks like it's
actually working right now so
i've called this talk das capital
critique history and
knowledge and i'll explain why i've
called it that and this is a bit of a
framing exercise
that sets up a philosophy and
methodology
so that what i say about capital the
text
and about marx makes some kind of
sense perhaps there's a bit of a health
warning
in that you probably won't get this kind
of outlook
or this kind of approach from the other
speakers in the
series most of whom i know and some are
quite
close colleagues but
i hope it's uh refreshing uh and there's
a bit of a methodological angle i'm kind
of inclined as
uh paul north will know from the
post-modern mark so
to take an idea and put it out very
clearly and
what some people consider to be an
extreme and unsettling form
uh just to see how much mileage there is
in the idea and what kind of pushback
uh there is on it so there should be
some lively debate
uh this evening so if i can
change the slide uh there we are i think
it's quite important in these
exercises whether literary or political
theory
to get visually acquainted with who it
is
that we're making speak to us
or imagining uh talking to us through
the text so um here we have
two images and marks these are actually
the first images
uh after the early 1840s the early
photographs
uh the one on the left uh 1861
and the one on the right 1867
just the years that uh
capital is published for the first time
so changing the slide um
this is the way i like to think about
marx this is him
in his uh university uniform
uh as a prussian student he's about 22
and he's just on the turn of
leaving university getting his phd by
post
which is a great idea and
uh leaving academia for forever and it's
quite important to understand
how repressive reactionary neo-feudal
know nothing the german
uh kingdom states principalities are
disunited as
they were into 40-yard units plus the
austrian empire uh how reactionary
unmodern
of this was uh in terms of being
repressive uh and
this applied to the university so his um
main tutor was chased out of the
university
uh carl knew that he was never going to
get a university job and he gave up on
that
pretty quickly so uh
the book on the left is um the sort of
volcanic one of
2018 that paul north was uh
talking about and the first chapter is
called making marx
so there are two things going on here
it's a kind of kind of double
hermeneutic really um that is we have
him here as a
student about to take a great turn in
his life
and embark on making himself himself
but the himself as he made himself isn't
really the same guy that he became
in what we call his uh reception or
how he was constructed and written up
for the history books and for the record
so that latter story starts in the very
early 1870s
and it's quite difficult to explain to
people now how
obscure he was how unfamous he was how
there were lots of
other guys around who didn't appear
to be that much different most of the
memoir
of votes we have a date from 40 years
later so
people constructed an idea after the
fact about what he was like
uh and then we can project that back
into the
letters and other things that we have
are actually contemporary
with this process but uh
methodologically i'm quite keen to
unpick and unpack
uh that kind of enterprise so in the
early 1870s
he was uh constructed uh as a guru
and in a sense a kind of founding father
of german socialism
right at the moment uh just after the
introduction of the imperial
constitution in 1871
when really for the first time uh
at least a few people could vote for
something uh
that might make some difference although
in practice
probably not very much again it's a
battle historically
to try to explain to people how deeply
undemocratic
uh even the constitutional regimes of
the times
uh actually were universal manhood
suffrage didn't hit the united kingdom
until the 1880s for instance and here we
are
uh only in the early 1870s
um in the reich
so at this point
of the two branches of the socialist
movement are getting together to unite
one uh had been led by ferdinand les
sala
he was rather conveniently dead and it's
quite easy to
honor people when they're dead and they
don't get in the way anymore
uh and those who had marks as a
mentor by correspondence because of
course he was
living in london and he visited him from
time to time and were
younger i thought that their grouping
within socialism their proto-political
party
um should have honorary founders to
rival the
um ferdinand lasalla who was really
quite famous
um in uh the german states at the time
which marx was not he had a certain
notoriety as a
48er who'd gone into exile because he
was prosecuted for treason
but that was about it so at that point
marx and angles were
created and constructed as important
thinkers
and at the time that was done um
not with dos capital which was recently
published but with the communist
manifesto
of 1848 marx and angles were quite
puzzled
by this and a bit standoffish and so
sort of wrote saying uh that thing is 25
years old
nobody's read it since we've really
pretty much forgotten it
it does get one footnote uh in das
capital interestingly but
nobody in 1867 could have got hold of a
copy
most of the copies had been seized by
the prussian police uh
it was really a rare pamphlet so
they said why on earth don't you write
your own which is you know
one for now which is quite a reasonable
political question however they were
persuaded to go along with this
process of constructing
icons and being made into
symbols and gurus who would have
works which were then uh republished
uh through the later 1870s 1880s
uh and this is part of the uh political
story
of socialism uh as an intellectual
movement so if uh
we go right back to uh
the beginning what actually happens
uh with young carl here as he's about to
leave university and can't get an
academic job
where exactly does he go
he goes to a newspaper office
that is in cologne not that far
up the river uh a group
of businessmen and fringe intellectuals
of the uh sort who are dedicated
to popular sovereignty liberalism
tinges of socialism derived from french
thinking
there are a little collective who want
to get a newspaper together
this is actually quite difficult and he
becomes
uh an associate and he tells us in his
own
ottawa autobiographical sketch of 1859
that it's in this office uh where he
first made contact with what he calls
quote
material interests unquote well this is
a well-known biographical fact
but i've chosen in chapter one in this
book to pause on that
and try to think it through quite
carefully
so here we've got a university student
from a professional
intellectual background in trier
uh provincial backwater uh comes to
cologne
where some enterprising types are
dedicating uh themselves to politics
trade and commerce this is quite a big
jump for an intellectual and marx
clearly found it
uh really stimulating in other words
from his education in philosophy
history and jurisprudence he had learned
really
nothing about trade commerce uh and what
industry right might be like given that
in
the german states there really was
hardly any and then i
tucked away um in
rather nasty little pockets so
in this office we don't know very much
about what happened
so not very much of this gets written
into the historical
record we know who the businessmen
were who were the backers of the paper
and who were um would be editors we know
whom they wanted to be edited which
wasn't marx it was
actually friedrich list the
um becoming
famous a political economist
in the german-speaking lands so
this was quite a new uh kind of
scientific
subject and it's important to understand
that in this kind of neo-feudal
reactionary order
making money through trade and commerce
was not very nice it wasn't something
that uh rulers really very much wanted
they wanted peasants with taxes and so
you know have an easy life and
be landowners and not have modernizing
change so um within this
reactionary regime the press is strictly
controlled as is
uh even conversation on subjects that
are taken to be
political which certainly includes
anything to do with religious doubt
and the police are around snooping on
people and giving them warnings
uh and all that kind of thing and of
course that had happened to
marx's father in trier so these are not
inconsiderable
kinds of things to reckon with when
you're
entering a newspaper office and
getting involved with people who do
believe in
liberalization to appoint uh believing
in popular sovereignty doesn't mean that
you believed even in universal manhood
suffrage far from it
most people who uh believed in some
version of popular sovereignty certainly
didn't think that uneducated people
should vote so the story of democracy is
not really about
the proclamation of votes for everybody
the story of democracy is really
much more about whom can we um continue
to exclude whilst including a few more
than were there before so
that's a bit of background so that this
chapter actually sets up and i think
that should do as a bit of an
introduction
to um how i conceive of
marx as an author and in particular
as a political actor and so
i'll come on to that first of all let's
go for some more
visuals um here we have um
das capital the book itself here's the
first edition again i think it's quite
important in these things to get some
sense of
physicality in the original so it's not
a kind of
disembodied text that just exists in
a logo world
meanings and concepts it's actually a
book written in
german for german speaking audience
that's what it's it looked like we know
from the first chapter where marx
mentions his earlier uh so-called half
volume or first installment
to a critique uh their politician
economy
uh and that's that edition that little
half volume
of 1859 um
some of my germanist friends uh can help
me out here
uh i'm interested in the transition from
the gothic
type face to the roman type face i mean
they've
they were both around i just wonder if
anybody thinks there's any particular
significance whether in the place of
publication or the target
audience i don't know uh gothic typeface
of course was around till
uh well into the 20th century and so
my german course in colombia we all
learned to read that
and i'm not sure that undergraduates
necessarily do that anymore so um here's
a couple of
things for us to look at to get us
in the mood and to looking the right
direction
part of this is to remind anglophones
um like ourselves in this gathering
that this is a german writing in german
for a german political audience marx's
political world
is really looking east he looks
westward to france for uh
culture for socialism for communism for
intellectual stimulation and for
political economy
uh in the first instance so educated in
the rhineland he was completely fluent
in french from an early age and if
you've seen the
uh the recent bio pic legend marks or
de younger marks that's something they
actually got right
in this german belgian uh
co-production uh the characters in it uh
speak quite indifferently to each other
in german and french
as they um go along with suitable
subtitling
um so uh we know
uh that uh in learning french
uh he also learned uh roman style
handwriting i did actually discover or
track down some previously unpublished
letters of his in london uh and when
these kind of fell out of a plastic bag
on someone's
kitchen table um i realized that i could
read
uh his handwriting uh quite easily on
uh some and so i thought well that's
because he's writing in english but
actually
he learned so to write cursive roman
when uh
as a schoolboy he learned french
otherwise he had the famously terrible
handwriting in german cursive
gothic which is almost impossible to
decipher
although i mean perhaps some of my
colleagues who
spend their time on manuscripts from
that era
so that's a little bit more background
i'm fighting against the idea
in the anglophone world that um
having removed to london in 1849 1850
and having
uh and living there the rest of their
lives into the 1880s and 1890s
uh marx and uh engels became honorary
englishmen uh and speak to us in english
and we now have
50 volumes of marx
uh translated uh into english
engels is a completely different case of
course
his english was very fluent in the uh he
wrote and published in it
from a very early age
barely 20 21 years old
because his dad took him on business to
england
uh if marx's english was much more
uh rudimentary learned rather slowly
uh he only got on with reading english
authors as the 1840s
progressed 1845 6. his first visit to
england is in 1845 with
engels to go to the library in
manchester
and um it's uh
his his english was workable and so he
he
uh for money i've got to write it quite
fluently in
the 1850s and early 1860s but i think
it's important to remember
that even in london his politics is
pretty much looking east and so
looking west to the u.s uh east coast
and the midwest to the german-speaking
communities there and some of you will
know that some of his works were
actually
published there within that community
so a little bit of philosophical
uh background just to uh
set things up i've put critique down
here
um to say that this is not just a method
or a
genre uh though it's that but for marx
it's actually
an ontology and an epistemology
so uh this is where things
get a bit um radical or extreme or
uh i mean paul north will know this from
the post-modern marx
that is it's an ontology and
epistemology that is
what there is to know and how we know it
of political intervention
uh in communicative practice and the
communicative
practice is meaning making
uh as a repetitious uh
citational activity so
that perhaps uh doesn't mean a lot on
its own but as the discussion goes on
uh i think it will become a little bit
clearer
uh i put everything i put history down
um
to um
put a few more things uh on the board
that is to say
within this ontology epistemology of
meaning making
everything is historical
human history making is what there is
and
historiography is what we say about
human history making that we want to say
and of course a lot
is excluded uh as we will know
uh from discussions uh about
historiography
uh and uh inclusion and exclusion
from about the last 40 years
this is because everything is
communicative
if we want it to be communicative
communicative that is if we're making
meanings
we project those meanings outwards and
then we read them off
as what the thing is or what it is
telling us
existence in a philosophical sense is
therefore
meaningful only within meaning it's not
something
outside of meaning that is a validation
point
for meeting so some people will
recognize this
um and it may seem a bit heavy for an
intro
but i hope it'll pay off or at least
give you the idea
of how this is uh set up
and not perhaps what you ordinarily hear
so within this
knowledge is always and already
purposive
it's not abstract uh
it's nor is it unconnected with
political projects so
one feature of capital of course is to
argue that political economy
the economics of the time is not a
disinterested science
done by scientists who stand uh outside
society and outside politics
it is rather itself a political project
and it says some things and obfuscates
or hides
others so that's all entirely
fair enough and to be expected from
this point of view science therefore
from marxian perspective and you can see
this in very early writings
is technology is industry
is commerce is capitalism
so there's no kind of disinterested zone
of
pure knowledge and ask anybody who knows
any scientists where their money comes
from
and you can see that this is
an ongoing uh idea
so um the uh
working through of this uh perspective
in terms of uh
and so his writings and how they can be
approached and i'm not saying this is
the only way
but just that it might be an interesting
and productive way and it does make a
bit of a change
uh for most people this philosophical
perspective
uh is worked out uh in a chapter
in this book which is published
it's chapter 13 and the title is their
socializing knowledge and historicizing
society marx and engels and the
manuscripts of 1845-46
so just to
geek out on this the argument
is put through from the roughest pages
of the manuscripts that have gone into
the
um so-called german ideology as the
so-called book with the so-called foible
chapter this argument is actually
fleshed out from these very very rough
pages which really are unique
uh in the legacy because they're the
only manuscript pages we've got
where marx and engels are actually
drafting things together
and the only pages that we've got where
they're making extensive
rough draft corrections crossing out
change we're changing one word
literally you know into another and
rephrasing things
as they go along so i uh in those
particular pages which actually they
excluded from the things they were
drafting
i think probably on grounds they were
too theoretical
um these pages are of interesting to us
and the object here is
not to turn marx into a philosopher or
an economist but rather to see
what an interesting view of
uh society knowledge and history arises
through this method of critique
and therefore i think you can see
a vocabulary kind of moving from one
word one phrase from
one phrasing uh to another uh
as that argument um develops
so um i'll leave these slides at this
particular point um
and uh do a little bit of reading i did
some pre-circulation of something that
i've written on capital it's actually
uh ten thousand words it's still in
draft
uh it's going into uh something that's
written for historians
um it's called bloomsbury the publisher
uh history theory and method
um and it's written through a kind of
template
so i'll read a few uh excerpts from that
to pick out some
quotes from this amazing book so that we
actually get to hear some of marx here
and not just to hear
me but uh
i thought it was quite an unusual
sort of puzzling choice
in saying that this
reference book chapter is going to be
for historians
and is um going to be about marx and
then
choosing capital because
it's not considered a work of history it
doesn't fit uh
historiography um as a genre
marx isn't really rated as a historian
by historians mostly
they've generally picked him apart where
they have
taken the view that he was doing history
but doing it
badly as i say he never had an academic
job didn't want to be
an academic historian or philosopher
or an economist so i was quite puzzled
uh
that they chose capital uh and also
uh quite excited uh but it is quite a
stretch
for historians as indeed as it is indeed
for anybody
uh to pick up this book and start on
page
one so quite a lot of this ten thousand
words is uh devoted
um to uh unraveling um
the the kind of
puzzle that paul north gave me in the
intro
that is how on earth do we start reading
this book and what do we make of it
well this kind of takes me back to the
political
context of the time virtually everything
marx
are published as opposed to just
wrote down in notebooks or manuscripts
had to get through a sensor and quite a
lot of his life he was trying to get
published in dodge
census and had all his
difficulties uh with that and indeed the
newspaper that he joined in 1842
was closed down by the censorship so
this is an ongoing
uh issue and a problem it follows that
if you wanted to
say anything much uh about politics
other than how good the rulers were
you were going to be scrutinized very uh
heavily and uh the rulers and the
religious establishments were all
entirely the same people
uh so um you you criticized their
religion you
overthrow society you upset politics
there's certainly no division of
anything they're
quite the opposite so they're always
kind of sniffing along on those
uh lines as well
so uh like
um so uh capital had to get around the
center
of like uh all of marx's works
uh and indeed those of his
contemporaries the uh the people he's
associated with
uh and writing with uh they write it
uh for publication in a kind of code
it's got to be coded
as uh philosophy or eventually political
economy
i think it's hard to make people
understand
that marx writes about hegel not because
he wants to
have a philosophical battle with a dead
philosopher
but because hegel is a political issue
and hegel is a political issue
because you can appear to talk about
philosophy
and actually in a coded way be talking
about
politics so you could get that kind of
thing through
the sensor and through the
academic authorities who of course um
made sure that conservative professors
were appointed
uh to give official lectures on hegel
and the
uh the more radical commentary uh comes
in the alternative
uh publications and that's the kind of
world that marx grew up in
or got to know himself in
uh in the 1840s so we've got that first
difficulty with capital what kind of
coding is it
uh it's very ironic uh
capital itself is a satire
he's setting the political economists up
for a fall
um he's um fooling us
really um i mean those of us in the know
would know
um that he's going to pull the rug out
from under them and that is a
critical work in a very serious sense
and it's not a minor
criticism but to get this past the
censor and indeed to get
um a a gullible audience
on board particularly among the
professors
as he said it's got to look like a sober
serious
a vision shaft like scientific work of
political economy and indeed uh
to a certain extent uh he thinks they
were onto something
and got it right in certain respects
even if he didn't like their politics
but they also got it wrong in a way that
he thinks
is really interesting and that he can do
things with
so there's an element of parody here
it's a very good parody
uh it is a difficulty with parodies that
if they're too
good the audience won't get the
satirical
difference between the parody satire
and the real thing
so there are two reasons there why it's
coded as a parody one is to get it past
the censor
the other is to get an audience on board
and then whoops
pull the rug out from under them which
he does
very neatly in the final chapters uh
part eight chapters uh 26 to
33. so i really argue that
for all these reasons
uh and others capital isn't a genre by
itself
uh it's not going to fit history or
sociology or philosophy
you've got to kind of get on board with
the author who's
setting his own genre in his own kind of
context
but he's in difficulties trying to
explain to you
particularly if you live uh you know a
hundred and uh
60 70 80 years later um
that's you know i mean he's not going to
know that so
though there is that element of
difficulty the political economy the
economics of the times is of course
quite different from modern economics
and here marx got a kind of rug pulled
out from under himself in the later
1870s there was what was called the
marginalist
revolution in economics
and the economists were pretty
suddenly thrown over uh as
passe and unscientific not doing the
right kind of thing in
the right way uh obsessed with
uh value and uh with
a kind of philosophical moral problem
which was where this profit come from uh
whereas in the marginalist world i mean
there really isn't a problem
about profit the only problem is uh
really
how do people make more of it um
and how to do that with numbers and the
empirical data
roughly speaking and to move out of the
sphere of production where marx and the
political economist
uh were in the first instance into the
fear of consumption
so modern my uh marginalist economics
really starts from the point of view of
the consumer with
uh consumers with money in their hands
ready to buy things and assume that
that is going to send a message to
producers uh
via this mechanism so the whole thing is
really turned upside down and inside out
um and marks i don't think ever ever
realized that
um exactly it was just something that
was really quite different and from his
perspective
didn't make any sense so um
trying to translate a critique of
political economy to make it accessible
for modern readers
it's quite a stretch so i congratulate
the two pools
uh in taking this on it'll be
fascinating um to read the
results so uh i'm not quite sure how
how i'm doing for time paul north can
you give me a
clue on this if you're feeling like
you're coming to an end
there's probably a lot of questions okay
um and you can fill in the details uh
in between people's questions so thank
you
for a great presentation and especially
for
setting capital and marks into
his context and its context
that's something that really was
forgotten often
in the readings of capital i want to
give the first question
to my collaborator paul writer
go ahead paul thanks uh charles it's
great to meet you thank you for the
for the presentation we've actually been
in touch a little bit
as well over the summer and and terrell
is a translator of marx too and so
uh when he talks about
the process of translating marx with an
air of sympathetic weariness or
something
you know where it comes from um but he's
produced some great translations and and
i admire his translations and
i have read a bit about this argument
that
capital is in a fundamental way a satire
and i wanted to ask you about that to
follow up a little bit because
one thing that i've i've noticed in
doing the translation
is that when marx translates
passages from political economy into
german he engages in what you might call
a strong a strongly domesticating form
of translation
meaning that he really integrates
their writing into his so that
stylistically there's
not much difference between the
quotations in his german
and his german and you would think that
if he were looking to identify this
or treat this as the object of his
satire
that he would that he would perhaps in
some way
keep it at arm's length from his own
style and the style
in capital most of the time it is
certainly not
i don't have the sense that it's meant
to be a satirical style it seems to be
something that he really
uh tried to make into an effective
instrument for
conveying his his uh his ideas it's a
really interesting style a style that's
very different from
19th century german academic prose i
mean it's marked in
various ways by uh as as coming from
that time
through all sorts of references i'm
sorry about the barking dog
pleasures of zoom um but uh it also
syntactically and in terms of word
choices it's so different from something
like
ranka it has this leanness the sleekness
to it a lot of the time
and he gives this political economy
that's often really windy and
florid and gives it a kind of leanness
and tautness
that it it it doesn't have doesn't
necessarily deserve and so
i'm wondering how that connects with
this
argument about the satirical
agenda in in capital um
well that's an extremely good question
um
he's doing a couple of things at once
it's not a straightforward
satire and we know from the 1840s that
he could write
straightforward ad hominem uh sarcastic
satires we know that from the holy
family in the poverty of
philosophy and we know that from the
kind of ad hominem
stuff that was going into the
manuscripts that never actually had a
title
till 1902 when they became known as the
german ideology
so we know he was very adept at that uh
and he's not doing the same thing
uh in capital it's a parody
uh so it's going to sneak up on the
reader uh and uh as the text progresses
you get more and more
kind of sarcastic uh comments
particularly in footnotes
uh but he's also at the same time
uh finding their work straightforward
and valuable descriptively
that is they are working with the
concepts of ordinary people and ordinary
commodity traders and merchants
and ordinary readers of newspapers like
the one
that he worked for politics trade and
industry uh and what he's
doing is you know writing both these
things at the same time
as indeed the political economists were
they weren't importing
concepts of they were reframing
and clarifying the concepts that were
already
in ordinary usage so marx is quite on
board with that because he's
looking at this clarified version of
what actually goes on
in commodity producing uh society
and he's actually uh buying into
the puzzle about profit uh
and he's just coming up with a new
concept and a solution
that they hadn't come up with but he's
coming up with a solution
that will pull the rug out from under
them and the solution
of course is the exploitation of labor
the production of surplus value
uh and that production uh as
the foundation of uh
capital as self-expanding value
so it's a very difficult book
uh in that way but um
you may disagree but i always find his
pros
very straightforward very lean very taut
sometimes um you know
well extremely sharp very combative
i read all of marx as political
intervention
from early 1842
and i mean all of it
he could write the kind of
intellectualized
journalism that he had to write at the
time to get into the paper and to
communicate
to that audience but it's not
as difficult as later 19th century and
certainly 20th century
uh academic german um and certainly
marx's prose i mean his
his best praise work for me is the 18th
premier of louis bonaparte i think it's
a fantastic text
and it's the worst translation in this
so-called standard
once into english that there is done by
uh daniel de leon so i really enjoyed
re-translating
that um and it's um
really explosive and uh at the same time
colorful
so i i think he's a fantastic
writer in prose if i had to pick
something
uh and my knowledge is not what yours is
as a kind of model i would have picked
the lutheran bible
i think that's actually you know direct
stuff thank you
tara thank you paul we want to
i think there's a lot of explosive ideas
in what you've been saying for the past
hour or so including that all of marx's
writing is a political intervention
not a science for example not
metaphysics
for another example and we can talk
about that
i want to just reiterate what this is
for those who may have come in
later this is all of our chance to be tv
radio announcers i guess
um and none of us have trained for it
we should keep in mind here that we're
being subsumed
into the apparatus in a way that marx
described and others have described
really eloquently and the
conditions of our intellectual work have
really changed a lot
it is a real pleasure to see how many
people are here
and i want to welcome you all
you will notice that we've jumped into
the middle
and a lot of us take for granted that
we've read capital
or know some things about marx terrell
gave a terrific
introduction to the context which is
often forgotten
and the arguments we haven't really
touched on today but
he knows them very well so you're
welcome to ask him
questions about value or about
labor what i'd like to do
is i'd like to give the students
in the seminar that is a regular college
seminar
that goes along with this workshop
series a chance to ask some questions
students if you want to begin if you put
your questions in the chat
i will then somehow get to you we'll
unmute you and you can ask
professor carver yourselves then after
that we'll open up
and uh i'll let you know for the rest of
those listening
when you can put your questions in the
chat we we really want to try to get to
as many as possible
so for students in the class i have
already
one in an email this is from i'm going
to read it since i have it here from
avery youngblood
who's a student in the school of art i
wonder what it means to
quote unquote shop small aka support
your local businesses
in terms of marx's views on private
property and work
workers versus non-workers there we go
right to the heart of the matter
um yes i agree private property is
the heart of the matter and this is
something that marx puts his finger on
already in uh 1842 there are some magic
moments in his
early newspaper articles and this kind
of brings me on to
uh my approach to the text
for the modern reader which is really to
start at the end
to start in part eight the so-called
uh primitive accumulation chapters 26
to 33 because i think those are the ones
that make the most sense
uh at the moment but to make sense of
those you have to see
as he explains in those chapters the
centrality of the developments of modern
private property
so the story for marx begins in 1842
uh with an article on the dispossession
of
uh feudal of peasants from uh
forestry where they had rights
subsistence rights uh to do various
things pick up firewood or whatever
it was they needed and so by uh
act of the local ruler this was going to
be
uh privatized turned into a piece of
private property
uh sold off to an owner who would
subdivide it and make farms
and they would all be stuck
uncompensated
uh of course so it's this process of
dispossession through which modern
private property is
created uh that sets
uh commodity production uh in motion
uh for marx such
that workers become available
to employers because they haven't got
anywhere else to
go and they can't go anywhere else
because they're denied access to the
land so
therefore uh they have to work for wages
and uh go into shops uh
to buy uh processed food so
which is then are produced for profits
uh elsewhere
in agribusiness uh and packaging and
processing so this is essentially what's
uh already going on in england in
scotland in the late 18th century
through
uh enclosures and dispossession and what
is going on in the
um colonies and uh including ireland
plantations were set up in
ireland uh and virginia at the same time
where uh labor costs were driven as low
as
possible than in the case of imported
uh forced labor to north america driven
down to zero
so we know what that is so property is
the crucial
concept and marxist
political intervention is to try
to wake people up to what is underneath
the normality
of clicking on amazon of going into a
shop with
chip and pin or however their you know
wireless
connectivity or an apple watch and
how the local global
distinction is itself a misleading one
um i was you know reflecting on this
only this morning and so i'm thinking
about
the supermarket where i go and i thought
what are the flags
that you see why do i see only union
jacks and by british and
it tastes better because you know like
tomatoes taste better because they're
british i mean
please uh you know if we had
little flags all over all those other
packets and labels particularly
indicating supply chains
we'd have a much better picture of
how i'm avoiding the word ideological
but how
mystificatory um the local global
uh consumerist position is and how it
takes away from the actual brutal hard
facts of
production which is really where marx is
starting
carol are you saying if i can just
follow up that
um the local is a
fiction and that really the supply
chains can't be
avoided when producing something like
that or that the local
is such a small fraction of the world
economy that it's inconsequential
uh it's not a fiction it's real it's
real because
people use the words and they believe in
the words and they organize their lives
around
these words but it's mystificatory and
this is uh
going straight from marx's uh playbook
uh capital uh section on fetishism of
commodities
um chapter one section four uh
i believe you can read the real stuff
there
where he describes
how economics and the political economy
of his day and ours
is a political project to ensure that we
see
some things and don't reflect on others
so it will hit some i don't know the
huffington post in the news sites
occasionally that so
apple workers in shenzhen uh you know
have terrible working conditions
well what should we think about that and
what marx is providing
or trying to provide is a framework
through which to understand that
and to form a judgment and he makes very
clear
uh with uh sarcastic comments and
eventually
a thinly disguised pro programmatic
one in um chapter 27 i think
uh where he's coming from and what he
thinks the solution is but he's got to
get past the
sensor and we all have issues with that
thank you i have two further questions
from
students in the seminar starting with
bilal who asks professor carver well
let's see if bilal can unmute can we
unmute billah let him speak for himself
this may require some technical
magic but yeah paul before we get
started there's a couple of questions
above if you scroll up so there's one
from a jonas and then a ryan offman
so jonas koka also had a question about
good
let's since i am going backwards let's
stick with billah for the first if
you can you can then we'll just we'll go
backwards through the list
thank you
right um thank you professor carlo i had
a question
uh from your text you mentioned other
contemporary texts that share uh you
know the title capital
and have a very similar approach and you
mentioned picatis capital in the 21st
century
and uh there are some i mean i saw
similarities between picatis
you know critique of capitalism and
marxist capital itself
but uh the methods are quite different
it's not really a traditional marxist
approach
so i was wondering how marx would react
you know his findings about inequality
in the 21st century
and the world that you know he describes
uh
well i think marks are definitely by the
book and by the next book
about ideology and capitalism which
essentially says
what i've just said in the previous
answer
that is a lot of effort goes into
helping us see things one way rather
than another
and not connecting the dots you might
say so i see
piketty in both books as trying to
connect up the
dots that mark said were there but doing
it with modern methods and particularly
with an absolute avalanche of empirical
examples
dating statistics and all of that i
think
marx was trying to get his hands on that
but of course in 1867
uh statistics data collection really
hardly
exist so i think one instructive thing
in reading a text from out of the past
like this is
to spend some time
trying to think about and to find out
about
what sources and what knowledge of
was even potentially available
to the person at that time if you think
about what mark says about china and
india for instance
how could he have known much of anything
and
in terms of the sources that he did have
available
what in fact were they this is still
very early days
in terms of even collecting uh
data that calls itself economic uh
about european countries and for
as far as uh trying to understand
uh societies you know outside europe i
mean this is really early days
uh also so there just actually isn't
um very much there i mean even if i
remember darwin is only 1859
uh and that's uh the origin of species
is
built on um geological knowledge from
the 1830s 1840s
onwards which was not accepted i mean um
i mean darwin was persecuted and
had endless uh problems for questioning
the bible
so if you look at the 1840s and ask well
what could marx possibly have known
about the roman empire the ancient world
uh or the ancient world outside the
roman empire you're not looking
at very much and quite a lot of it is
going to be located in around
the bible they're certainly filtered
through that
so i think one has to bear all those
things in mind but i think he'd be
delighted with pikachu's books i think
they're great
can i follow up bilal thank you very
much
this is a little bit more of a
provocation i think but
um piketty in the first book called
capital
focuses on inequality and his solution
is something like redistribution through
taxation
do you think if marx had the statistics
that he would come down
he would have been a liberal um well i
think there's
little difference between marx and
liberals to start with
but there is some difference so as i
said marx is fully on board with popular
sovereignty and universal male suffrage
which was actually in the french
constitution
of 1793 uh they just
didn't put it into practice uh and this
i say was first put into practice in
1848
so remember uh you know it's commonly
said marx is you know
very influenced by the french
revolutionaries but he's v
he's very close to the french revolution
of 1830
which is the constitutional monarchy i
mean that's
that in his lifetime so i think again we
need to need to get
um close to where these people actually
are to
understand what it is that they're
thinking about
uh and the suffrage is so somewhat
widened at that point
so marx does face a political dilemma
from the beginning
because as early as 1842 he's on to the
private property
thing uh and the suffering of the
peasants
so on the one hand the liberal
businessman would like to get
the peasants into the shops
with money and the government doesn't
really want them
into the factories because they don't
really want factories
and uh the charity angle isn't working
out so what the business men are really
upset about
uh is the town filling up with beggars
this is going to be really annoying for
people who want to shop
so that's why they want friedrich list
to come in and
help the prussian government
uh sort themselves out
but they don't want too much messing
with private property or
too much uh redistribution they just
like some economic
uh organization of wage labor
which they think would be quite
beneficial if it requires disposition
uh dispossession that's quite okay with
him
and actually it's quite okay with marx
at that point
since uh he's got to have allies those
who believe
uh in the collective ownership of
property rather than the
uh ownership of private property
particularly
in the means of production such as land
uh though there's going to be a tension
there so he's got to keep that kind of
quiet
um and moses house was involved with
this everybody was looking
for a solution so these people have got
to work together and that's what marx
did in the rhineland it's what he did in
paris
it's what he did in brussels uh there
weren't enough socialists around
and they weren't collected enough on
what an earth they meant
by collective ownership of property
anyway um to make much of a case so
they're still working that out
they're just trying to get rid of
reactionary
you know religious fanatic maniac
um authoritarian rulers who can be
really really annoying
and you know really frustrating and
don't want anybody to vote for anything
and even in the french republic hardly
anybody voted for anything
anyway so their first angle was
democracy and if you look
at the end of the communist manifesto
part four there's a list of demands all
of which are basically liberal demands
um including nationalization of the
banks and provision of
uh work for the disabled and provision
of work for everybody
and free public education which is
unknown at the time
uh and all of those other kinds of
things it's not a word about the
uh abolition of private property it's a
strictly redistribution and if you look
at the fly posted 17 demands
which of the communist party which marx
and engels actually
got fly posted around in
the german states as opposed to the
manifesto which went nowhere except the
prussian police
archives the fly posting which they
signed
which got angles into terrible trouble
in this hometown
uh is a straightforward list of those
demands
all of which are impeccably liberal so
you've got to have allies i mean marx
was you know
uh politically astute
and it's so it's you know he was making
political intervention so
i don't think there's a problem there
liberals may have thought there was a
problem
and they were nervous
nice thank you very much i want to turn
to
ryan offman can we unmute ryan for his
question
hello hello hi ryan we hear you
awesome so my question was kind of on
your description of marx's relationship
with science
i think there was a slide on it earlier
and i i
very much agree that when i'm when i'm
reading his descriptions i think it's a
very very like cynical
um view of how science works and that
very well might be
the case do you think it's more of a
general
something about the nature of science
that marx thinks is fundamentally going
to kind of boil down to capitalism or is
it more about the specific institutions
that marx was kind of raised on like i'm
sure
he hit the university he was at had a
quite demanding and
quite specific way of dealing with
science
uh thank you great question the
university went to had no science at all
so in the sense that we have it it was a
traditional and reformed university so i
would
go back to the educational milieu of
the uh 1820s 1830s
and this year's continuous uh up
to and beyond the 48 uh
revolutions and it's uh quite an
intellectual revolution
led from berlin and from the
um the uh prussian royal university
there and it's not from the traditional
universities
um like bonn so
um vishenshaft and vincent schafflicht
um in the german at the time this is a
rigorous study of anything
i mean hegel's system building on any
subject whether metaphysics or nature
or logic was this and shaftly
because it was rigorous and indeed
modern science uh
you know accepts the same thing it's
supposed to be
rigorous and logical in the first
instance
so what you get from
the more sort of
anglo-centric and so later
um reformed german universities this
conception of science
that accepts a physical materialism
which can only really uh get to be
respectable after darwin and you know
people have got away with
a kind of separation in metaphysical
terms between
uh faith and the material uh
world and as that is becoming more
technologically successful and
engineering is
uh engineering and early uh physical
material
science we're all the same thing anyway
electricity physics and
all of that stuff if you go back through
the
history of science and technology uh
they're all the same thing from about
the 1760s 1780s
onwards so these things all have to have
a use
and the experimentation has to be
paid for uh and it's often quite
difficult to do so i would approach this
very much and try to make sure that
we're not
projecting a kind of scientific
materialism matter in motion and
mathematical methods from the 1870s and
1880s and onwards
back on to something that really didn't
exist
anywhere uh very much
um and in marx's time
so i'll just pull the 1844 manuscripts
out of a hat here this is another
sort of editorial uh kind of geeky point
these are kind of ripped out of marx's
notebooks
and turned into a manuscript work uh in
the 1920s but
even so you can see there he actually
just says
uh that um insofar as we have vitten
schafflich's study of the
material world uh it's driven by
and you know goes into
technologies of ordinary life and that's
what industry is
marx is very fixated on technologies and
therefore economics of
ordinary life in whatever stage of
society we're
looking at so uh he quite specifically
says that his overall
outlook which is
uh historical all the way down uh
includes
uh all previous forms and stages if you
like or formations
of society in terms of the way uh that
people
interacted together to get along in the
material world it just takes different
forms at different
times but um he's quite happy and this
is actually in
capital with the um stone age bronze age
in iron age
that actually gets a footnote and that
was a new thing
uh in the um 1860s series quite
interested in
stone age uh technologies and
it might sound odd to call this stone
age science but in terms of being
rigorous and logical and apparently not
doing what
baboons or apes do when they use
simple tools i mean he's definitely onto
something
thank you thanks ryan we have one more
student with a question
can we go to jonas kilga
hi um can everyone hear me
yes awesome um thank you uh so
you mentioned censorship a lot uh in
your talk
and in the text that you sent out you
also said he published this capital in
hamburg
originally because the sensors were more
lenient
and i think when you're reading marx it
is quite a
peculiar language and maybe that's just
1860s german
um but knowing about the censorship
or that he had to grapple with it i was
wondering concretely
um how capital
was affected uh by censorship uh if
there are any
if there's textual evidence to look out
for where you can sense that marx was
sort of trying to
ride around certain um certain
stipulations put in place by sensors
well i think there's an awful lot of
that i mean you have to put yourself in
the mind of the
sensor of the time and then in marx's
mind
to try to figure out what he's not
writing um
but uh there's quite a lot of quotation
from
published sources some of which is
quite critical of capitalism so
um that that's a move i mean uh none of
these moves are guaranteed to get around
the
uh censor i was particularly struck in
reading part eight
uh again that we get to an apocalyptic
moment of capitalist collapse
uh where he describes the uh
proletariat uh overthrowing uh
the regime of private property and says
it's a it's the negation of the negation
well this is sort of pounced on in the
post 1920 world of mark's receptionist
showing that he still valued hegel
uh i think this is really a way of
getting around the
um censorship by um
not saying too much about this
um you know volcanic change in the
social order that he's envisioning
and quickly covering it up with a kind
of meaningless philosophical
uh phrase that doesn't say much of
anything
and then moving swiftly on all of this
of course only comes in part eight by
which time you assume the censor has
got very bored and uh so
censors were known um you know to read
kind of the beginning and
you know bit of the end and kind of flip
through
because you know they they're on a
paycheck they had books to get through
so um marx is pretty successful with
that and it's word of mouth where you go
for your publishers and there's a lot of
uh that in correspondence
um about where to go and who will put up
the
money for it and how to get the money
whether you split the course with the
publisher and how much risk the
publisher is going to take
uh and all that kind of stuff but
publication was not free
it was censored and as i point out uh
they were lucky to get through the
russian censorship
not least uh again in a sense on a kind
of foreign angle there's an awful lot of
foreign writers in there so
we don't have to worry very much and um
capitalism was a wholly foreign idea
um in russia in the early 1870s it was
so new
the censor hadn't really heard of it
didn't know what to do with it it seemed
it was of
no interest in a really autocratic
medieval
um you know obsessive uh feudal setup
so said it was kind of a tedious work on
a subject nobody knows anything about
so you kind of have to rely on sensorial
um ignorance it's not as well developed
as censorship has been in
other places thanks terrell
i'm sure all the hegelians in the
audience will have been interested
hegel's speak in the book was an attempt
to get around the
sensors i would like to open up the
floor for questions from
all the spectators now we have some in
the chat
i wonder if we can actually unmute the
folks
and have them ask their questions let's
try yes mean if you're
on we have a question from sarah
wechsler you think we can
find sarah wexler and unmute
sir you should be able to unmute
yourself hello
hi we hear you okay yeah i recently read
william claire roberts book
um marx's inferno and he's also kind of
trying to politically contextualize
capital and so i was just wondering if
you if what you thought about his take
that um
marx is sort of advocating for some sort
of republicanism
um when he's writing capital
well i fairly recommend the book then
not
a whole lot of books on this subject i
recommend but that's
clearly one i think his take on the
political intervention is
wonderful it's quite clever he
says it's written within the context of
the international working members
association
to which ladies were admitted um
and that it's really getting it prudenti
although prudent
is hardly mentioned in the text
so i think that's a little bit of the
uh parody satire uh angle marks had
already done a
sort of straight up satirical attack on
prudence so there's
not too much point doing it again um
better just to show what he wanted to
show which is that he was very much
better at it than
prudent and instead of riling the
fredonians he would kind of
pull a fast one on them so i think will
is
absolutely right about uh that
um i'm less on board with
the republicanism thing uh quite a lot
of
people thought that was a little bit
unnecessary or projected
i'm you know more inclined to stick with
popular sovereignty and liberalism
although
they are part of the same dialogue so i
don't go all the way with will on that
one
um i think the dante's inferno thing
is quite clever um it
shows an awful art of really geeky nerdy
grad
student research he taught himself you
know
the whole world of dante anna in order
to do this so
it's an awesome uh thing to take on
board
um for me it didn't actually add that
much to
my reading of capital to see it passed
out uh
as a kind of tribute to dante it's also
been passed out as a kind of tribute to
hegel's logic
i think it's got a logic of its own one
of the
points i make in the text is
that where is capital is actually quite
a good
question because it's a project i think
from 1842 and from late 1843 when he
uh reads engels's outlines of a critique
of political economy
and just goes electric he then sketches
out
a plan for a critique of political
economy
and spends the rest of his life on that
and we've got
a lot of manuscript build up
and reading notes and notebooks that
lead up to this
and we've got the intense
uh activity 1857 uh
onwards that got published eventually is
grindrous
we've got uh drafts of capital volume
one
and we've got his rewrites and new
editions in the french translation
uh of it um and
so therefore capital one is more like a
taster volume or a snapshot
and we know he was kind of pressured as
usual by family and friends to get
something out
so it's not thrown together but it's um
you know he had he had to make a stop
with it and decide what was going to be
in it as a single
volume work there's also a bit of a
health warning on volumes two
and three volume three is from
manuscripts that predate volume one
volume two is in a very rough state and
angles uh
editing is subject to a lot of critique
not all of it unsympathetic it's you
know editors have a hard job when
authors don't make up their mind and say
contradictory things
and i think that's a big clue about marx
he was really curious
and really exploratory
and you know was didn't feel obliged
to have a dogmatic view unless he'd
really thought about it
and then i don't think he particularly
wanted to be dogmatic
and said in a letter that he wasn't a
marxist
um well no i i'll correct you if i may
on that
engels reports in two letters uh that he
heard marx say
two different ways in french got it
let's turn to some other questions i'm
going to go
through the chat now so let's see if we
can
unmute hi can everyone hear me yeah
absolutely okay okay
so um this is a question about the labor
theory of value
i was thinking i was i was wondering
what you think about the labor theory of
value or
and whether it has some grain of truth
to it today uh
almost everything has a grain of truth
and i certainly think that
um i think we have to go back to
political economy and as i said the
puzzle that they were solving at the
time
and the way that they chose labor
as a common factor and they were
presenting a puzzle about profit and
solving it
or trying to solve it in very
aristotelian
terms so it's a very classical uh
problem
they're trying to solve with uh tools of
moralizing uh
philosophy which is somewhat connected
with the empirical world that is they
took
uh human labor to be an empirical kind
of
uh object uh
that's uh works in that kind of neo
aristotelian framework as far as it goes
uh excuse me there's a couple of
chapters in the post-modern marks
um that show how it works in that
context
uh and why if you shift your ground to
modern physics or a more uh
you know post aristotelian materialist
uh physical understanding of the world
based on physics and chemistry
it really doesn't work well at all
uh even just empirically it's not clear
that there's something that we can
specify
or define as labour in the human
context as opposed to leisure
though people talk as if there is
we can define things like wage work and
employment ask anybody in a tax office
what employment is and they will tell
you but they probably won't tell you
what work
is or what labor is
it's a convenient sort of label one
student said well
what about donkeys and animals who work
we have a lot of working out
hard-working animals
uh around the world why are they not you
know
since they're doing the same kinds of
things that humans are
doing we've got animals that are working
for us biologically now
and in modern terms i don't think there
are very good answers to those questions
alternatively we can turn it around and
say well let's
look at the world of production from the
point of view of the human being
and what human beings are uh required to
do
because they can't subside uh
they they can't subsist uh otherwise and
then i think we're much more on board
with the theory of exploitation which is
really
where marx's uh concept of labor power
and surplus value is going he's
developing a concept of exploitation
there are various ways you can uh
construct
empirical proxies for this and there's
quite a lot of mileage in
doing that marxist economists have
done that in very respectable work which
gets a very good audience
uh it also gets it gets ignored
uh because it doesn't start out with the
concepts and the method
uh that more orthodox uh economists
are used to working with i think pikadee
is a nice point of compromise there
uh he's quite interested in human beings
and the things that they're required to
do
within the productive setup that
capitalism
uh causes of them to be unmashed in
whether they like it
or not and some of them like it and some
of them
don't and people change their views
about it
as life goes along you may think it's
great when you're employed and
not when you're not so
there's all those things going on i
quite like david harvey's approach which
is really
to zoom in at volume two stage and look
at capital as flows and in a sense
uh just uh kind of put the whole
labor value thing on the back burner uh
and look at capital flows and then come
back round
to uh let's look at workers and their uh
kinds of conditions so there are lots of
things to be
done with i think it is quite difficult
to pick up
capital volume one and start on page one
and figure out
what is going on and why things are
problematic and puzzling and what the
concepts
mean and what they don't mean given
what's happened
in the uh 180 years or so
afterwards and we don't want to give
people too much of a freight so that
they don't
try it
your own quote i do think should come
back in here
okay it's worth it as all difficult
things are
and since we have to live under capital
it can't be worse than that
i want to go now to a question that was
posed a little while ago by martin
bradbury
i wonder if we can unmute martin if he's
still in the
hello hi martin hello uh
so my question is about
um the relationship between hegel and
marx
hegel's already been mentioned um and
from some of my readings of
primarily the from the frankfurt school
so like adorn edwin mark who was a
i've come to sort of understand marx's
project as
basically an attempt to radicalize hegel
um there's uh some uh there's
uh there's a section in the economic
philosophic manuscripts of course where
that's dedicated entirely to
criticizing cable there's a famous quote
from marx where he talks about hell when
he was uh
writing the grundery so he happened to
leave through hagel again
so this is something that keeps coming
up through the history of marxism
but um it's also been counted of course
by other
schools the one that comes to mind i
suppose it's like the analytical
marxists [ __ ] marxists we don't
might call that hegelian
speculative philosophy so my question
really is
to what extent is this idea that
marx was trying to radicalize hagel
something that
marx would probably have agreed with or
is it a distortion that's been
brought into it by marx's interpreters
like marcus and people that came
afterwards
well um thank you very much for that
question it's all of those things
so if we go back to the beginning um
who was hagel in the first place hegel
was an academic philosopher
he uh published a lot to the german
speaking
audience he was famous as a critic of
kant uh he uh
wrote uh a philosophical system which
was going to make
this in shaft lick a rigorous sense of
everything that ever
was and will be everything you could
possibly
want to know about he was famous in his
own time
much admired his disciples collected his
writings and filled out his
uh collected works in the 1830s and he
was
as we say in britain by the 1830s
a national treasure
he had become the east prussian
philosopher of choice
he was there in the public view
since the public was not allowed to have
a view about very much
and there wasn't even really supposed to
be
a public interested in politics because
he was so
famous and so famously ambiguous and
because he covered
everything including
history and politics he was away in
to the politics of the time he was the
politics
of the time in that you could discuss it
in a coded form
by talking about him
so there was no need to radicalize him
he was already
radicalized by the 1830s and he was
already
conservativeised by the 1830s
this debate was already raging
and uh he was blamed in the culture war
of the time for uh destroying
christian faith um and
and um preaching atheism uh but also
defending the prussian state and
orthodox confessional
christianity so this shows you the
advantages
of ambiguity and also the advantages of
being dead
and of being a national treasure so he
was the national philosopher
and how to read and understand him
particularly what he says about
um the on political subjects
in the philosophy of right his uh
political philosophy philosophy of the
state
and society and the family he's covered
all those things
uh what you think he's saying uh is
itself a political issue and this is
debated
uh and published on in the alternative
press
and in the official press and
professors are impo appointed by the
state
and kicked out by the state to take uh
the right view
on this philosophical subject so
um the uh 20th century
reception from the 1920s onwards doesn't
quite
see this the people who do it already
academic
uh philosophers and are not reading the
politics
of the time they're coming out marks
making him as a philosopher which was
already
going on in the 1880s um rather weirdly
angles of course wanted to make him a
materialist philosopher and therefore on
board
with the physical science of the time
and a hegelian systematizing
philosopher to keep him in the german
mainstream doing both of these at the
same
time in his works of the 1880s
when he revisits the 1840s and this of
course
not really very accurate 40 years on
in his recollections so this is a
complicated story of overlapping
receptions
um one can make uh
marx into a uh hegelian
i think it's really part of the politics
of the 1920s
where people are trying to read marks
outside of the orthodox marxist
materialist
framework of deterministic laws they're
picking up on hegel who
whom they assume can only be read in an
idealist way
they don't quite want to say that marx
is an idealist
he's just a hegelian they pick up on the
young hegelian discourse
which they can find um in the marx
archive and then do some research on uh
which had been um left over and ignored
engels doesn't really revive it
and actually nobody revives it because
everybody is on board with materialist
science
until the 1920s and we get this hegel
revival
both in weimar germany and
in france so some of the most
influential
french hegelian reception of marx
comes in lectures actually given at the
sorbonne
so i give them some credit in that
they're reading marks outside
the materialist orthodox deterministic
framework
um on the other hand i think they
mistake
uh where those works and texts are
actually coming from
and it kind of de-politicizes it as a
makes
what i think is actually an exciting
political intervention
we have four questions in the chat
i think i'm going to count the fourth
from marco lada as pretty well answered
he or they asked whether dialectics and
critique were terms in common use
given what you've said about hegel and
the million which marx was writing i
think it's pretty clear that they were
but marco if you have more specific
questions about that you could certainly
write professor carver myself then let's
go to isaac kirk
davidoff if he's still in the room
yeah hi um professor carver i just
wanted to know that
like there's so much imagery in capital
there's like tables
dancing there's vampires he references
like robinson crusoe
and what's my favorite footnote of
capital um and just want to know what
you make of all the imagery like is he
uh is this like reaching to describe
things that like political economy
doesn't have a language for that marx
doesn't have a language for
or is it more like just for the sake of
the reader like
um what do you make of all this imagery
well i think that's a really interesting
question and
my story on this is that in the early
1980s
i gave a word by word chapter by chapter
class
with um someone else's seminar class uh
on capitol and i've i gave it several
years running
um and so i got a little bit
daydreamy um going through
the book you know of chapter one for the
nth
time so i got out my little yellow
highlighter
and just started highlighting the images
because i was interested in metaphor
uh at the time and i began to realize
that there's
a whole world of occult imagery
there some of which is biblical from
revelation um and some of which just
derives from
you know the occults like the tables
turning this
famously the vampires there's werewolves
so i
i've got up my highlighter and i made a
list
and i wrote a short article which was uh
published in the then
times literary supplements and it's one
of the chapters
in the postmodern marks which you might
enjoy
and the further answer is i thought well
what is all this doing there that's just
not just to entertain us
there must be some kind of thread so
i think the thread goes like this it's a
classic
kind of enlightenment argument against
ignorance and superstition and it's
coded um against of
religion uh in general and it does
actually
tie into political economy so the
argument goes like this
okay enlightenment of post-alien
liberals of the time those who've read
david friedrich strauss
on strike on the life of jesus and don't
buy the literal truth of the christian
confessional anymore
we know you're all past that look what
i'm
showing you um is that
the world of commodity production uh
which we're looking at
through empirical testimony and
through works of political economy
is just as mystificatory and just as
performative as we might say these days
that is commodities are as
mark says really strange you just think
there's something in a shop with a price
tag
but let's try to think about them as
really weird
uh how is it that they have a price on
them what does price
mean uh he says prices are the language
that commodities speak to each other
this is getting really strange and
stranger
how is it that we have markets uh with
forces moving by themselves which we
have created
that control our lives in which we bow
down and worship
this is the fetishism of commodities
well
fetishism at the time wasn't freudian uh
it was um the projection of human
qualities on to stone idols
such that they command the humans or
seem to and the humans believe
that the stone idols have magical powers
and money
and monetized behavior uh
and all the things that neo-liberals
complain about
uh and all the boxes we have to take on
the tax forms are just all
instances of being trapped within this
uh performative uh ritualistic
world of commodity concepts that we all
believe in
because we have to but hey look
historically
this was made up historically there was
a time when we didn't have money we
didn't have commodities
we didn't have capital we got on we
traded things we produced things
uh let's not go back there but let's
realize
that commodity production and capitalism
don't have to be here
uh forever so there's a historical
argument going along there along with an
intellectual argument
which is that okay um
woke up liberals you don't believe in
this religious stuff anymore
apply the same argument to the commodity
stuff
it's just as weird as believing in the
incarnation
uh and the holy spirit and the
immaculate conception
it's just it's got dressed up as
political economy
or economics and we don't have to bow
down in worship once we realize
it's a collection of uh human concepts
that we
act out so there is a substantive way
that some people could have recognized
and it's part of the satire
um it's just not uh because it works
both ways i mean it's outlandish to say
the capitalists are werewolves and
capitalism is a vampire sucking the
blood of the workers
but there's loads of empirical stuff put
in there to show exactly that
and marx quotes horrifying stuff by the
time you get
to part eight about what happens in the
indian so-called mutiny
and other things like that from the
mouths you know from the writings of
colonialists and anti-colonies
uh themselves so the whole thing is very
joined up you just have to get all the
way
through to part eight uh to see
how it works where horror meets horror
you have two more questions i'm mindful
of the time people in
the east on the east coast want to get
to dinner and
people in the uk want to get to bed so
let me just give you
a summary of the last two questions one
is from
ali ekdahl who's a student in the
seminar and this follows up on the last
things you were saying what do you think
about the theological rhetoric in
capital that marx occasionally uses
like quoting jesus they know not what
they do
is this um a satire he asks
or is this uh putting himself into a
messianic position
and the last question is going back to
what you said about the
the communist manifesto isn't it unfair
to characterize the demands of the
manifesto as liberal
given the politics of the time it was
opposed by liberals as you
said wouldn't it be uh more
likely to think of it i guess he means
as communist or at least supporting the
workers struggle
okay i think um anything from the from
anything about the purports to come from
religion that said by marx with a
straight face is
totally satirical um he
uh arrived at atheism very early on and
this put him on the you know the radical
edge of everybody
uh you could be seriously persecuted you
wouldn't
uh you couldn't get a job you you
couldn't do do anything much of
anything uh as an out now atheist if
you know word got around about you
so that is all totally satirical it
belongs to the same thing
uh as um putting
um you know this is a powerful argument
so i mean the whole business of
uh economic production under capitalism
uh in the same box uh as religious faith
seems to be a serious category mistake
we're used to keeping them in separate
boxes so well
i go to the shops but then i have my
faith uh elsewhere and marx is saying
well look it's the same kind of
socially made-up phenomenon um
and so i mean marx went the whole way uh
with foie mark and
strauss which is that religion generally
and christianity of course
as part of that is a projection of human
ideas concepts and values onto things
that
are either stone idols or don't exist or
are truths you know that supposedly come
from books that
uh all of which require human
interpreters in authority structures
so um i mean that's uh deeply satirical
what's interesting is uh how how
learned he was on christianity and
bible study i mean he really knew it off
uh completely and he's completely expert
with it and it's great language and it's
another reason why
i think the lutheran bible is really the
key to his
prayers um the uh other question about
liberalism i think we have to go back
again to the politics of the time when
being liberal
the german-speaking state wasn't being
liberal it was being
treasonous um you know
you could be put in jail for advocating
popular sovereignty for
advocating constitutionalism um it was
horrendous
and remember that the french revolution
of
1830 is you know
easily living memory i mean you know
it's their own
lifetimes i mean the the rulers east of
the rhine
are terrified that's going to happen to
them the mob
are going to come and get them demand
more votes for more people
uh and rather unfortunately for them
louis philippe
um sort of ran off um didn't defend his
throne he ran off to twickenham
in london and set up his kingdom in
exile and
got to be pals with queen victoria so um
that's you know they were really
terrified of this
and um so to come back with our idea
that we're all in a system where
um liberalism is you know part of the
mainstream one and you know the opposite
is communism
really mistakes the politics of the
period
uh quite badly so those those demands
are
revolutionary demands for
constitutionalism
and they those people who signed those
demands
got put on trial marx argued his way out
of a
jury conviction and got tried in
absentia
and some of these people went to prison
and they went into
exile and they didn't all go to nice you
know places even as nice as
soho in london which wasn't very nice
this is a way to just pause
a much longer discussion about marx and
his radicality
you've given us a really radical reading
i think
and a lot to think about i want to thank
you very much for
your time and your effort and all your
work over many years to be able to sum
things up so
beautifully for us uh thank you
it's been an absolute delight i've
enjoyed the questions obviously very
considerably
i'm tempted to go back to share screen
and
show you the uh the book with the
volcano on the front
uh that was actually my idea in that
the publishers wanted um nature
on the cover and uh
i thought well nature i looked at their
covers which were all gardens
which was i thought well that isn't
going to do what garden is you know
mark's going to uh evoke so
um i thought well let's go from metaphor
so i thought about the great wave a
tidal wave with tsunami you know
some sort of unstoppable force um
and the designers came back um
and they said well here's some great
waves including hiroshige
um who's out of copyright and they said
but it does make it look like a surfing
book
um and i and they said well how about
volcanoes
and i said hey that's a great idea so
they came up with a volcano
and a few weeks later i happened to be
reading marx's
uh speech to the people's paper which is
a very early work written in english i
think
not entirely by him uh he actually talks
about
uh the forthcoming union of the
proletariat
um as a volcanic eruption so
um the book channel is marx i mean
that's obvious
anyway thank you very much it's been
delightful thank you terrell given the
amount of people who are
in the audience it sounds seems like the
magma is getting hot
i want to say to everyone before they go
that this series so beautifully kicked
off by professor carver is going to go
on next week marcelo musto
mosto from york university is going to
be here
we will have william claire roberts
talking about the literary dimensions of
the text
we have people talking about
reproductive labor
about racial capital about the economic
questions
so i hope you tune back in for the rest
of the series thanks very much
thank you